hi I'm Steve Kaufman here I'm back in
the desert I'm back in Palm Springs
where my wife and I like to come down to
avoid the rain in Vancouver
ah it's nice down here it's sunny my
eyes a little bit irritated to have to
take drops I get itchy but I'll get over
that presumably pretty quickly today I
want to talk about power language
learning I want to talk about my latest
challenge where I'm trying to sort of
focus on three languages everyday and
specifically on link I'm going to sort
of create 100 links in each language now
on link what we call creating a link
means clicking on an unknown word a blue
word and converting it to a yellow word
now if I find a blue word that is a name
I then ignore it or give it an X that
doesn't count as a created link it
doesn't add to my known where to my
saved links total only new words that I
save that become yellow that I can
review later on count so a hundred links
a day that's gonna be my driver now a
couple of comments on that and I'm
responding to some questions that I got
here when I announced this the first
time first of all once a week at least
once a week I'm gonna put out this power
language-learning week this is week one
I made to another week one a a week two
and in all theirs whatever it is nine
months 36 37 weeks that I'm gonna pursue
this strategy so to answer some
questions first of all why well I had
been studying the three languages Arabic
Persian and Turkish and I found that if
I did three months on one three months
on another and so forth it was six
months before I came back to the first
one and I would slip that's point number
one
however I do think that starting out in
a language very different languages
Turkish Arabic and Persian it's probably
worth it to focus for the first three
months on just
language or in the case of Arabic it was
even longer because I have to learn the
script there are a number of things that
require that sort of undivided attention
but now I want to grow in those
languages and I want to grow in all
three of them so I've decided to do them
all free of them every day so why a
hundred Lee lakes a day in each language
because that's the only way I can make
sure that I'm spending enough time on
each language or that I don't get
carried away and spend too much time on
one language so every day my task is
I've got to create a hundred links so
what does that mean first of all I have
to find material that has enough blue
words unknown words in it I either find
them in our library or I go find them on
the internet that can be a bit
time-consuming so I have to find
podcasts in Arabic or whatever I have to
get them transcribed on the automatic
transcription service I have learned
that I have to choose podcasts where
people speak clearly in order to get a
proper transcript typically the content
that I'm bringing in in Arabic Turkish
and Persian is going to have 30 to 40
percent unknown words including place
names which I don't count know so one of
the reasons I do it is because I want to
make sure I spend enough time on each
language the second reason is because I
found that in each of the three
languages I had put so much effort into
my mini stories that I had listened to
30 or 40 times that I had reread three
four five six times or even on some of
the podcasts that I had converted to you
know yellow words and I was reading them
for the second with the third time and I
was starting to find this boring and I
said I've got to push myself out of my
comfort zone so if I set miles myself as
a goal every day
in each language I have to create 100
new links I have to get to new material
and it's in fact more interesting even
if the comprehension is not really there
to plow forward in new material because
I can look up every word because in the
case of Arabic and Turkish I can hear it
pronounced in text-to-speech not
available in Persian unfortunately so I
can get a good sense of what these items
are and it's interesting to plow forward
for example I tweeted out yesterday that
yesterday I read and listened although I
didn't understand fully a TED talk by a
young Turkish woman who had cancer and
had her leg amputated a description of
the sustain iam dynasty or dynasty in
ancient Persia from person online and a
discussion on cosmic at about the hijab
and secularism and Islam in French
society all three subject very
interesting so basically I'm interested
in the subject matter I'm plowing
forward saving new words not learning
them but just saving them for later
and I am kind of reading and getting
some overview of the language because
okay so that so that's so I'm doing
things that are more interesting I'm
forcing myself to move forward get out
of my comfort zone I'm making sure that
I put enough time into each language so
another question was how long does it
take so I tied myself this morning
obviously Turkish is the fastest because
it's written in the Latin alphabet so I
can read faster also I have them I have
typically a higher percentage of new
words in Turkish for whatever reason
then in the other two languages so to
get to a hundred links in Turkish took
me about 15 minutes in Persian and
Arabic it takes 30 minutes so that means
that an hour and 15 minutes an hour and
a half a day
has to be spent on creating these links
in the three different languages so if
you are only doing one language you can
still force yourself to do 300 links a
day like I'm doing and it should take
you an hour and a half okay you're
you're not trying to remember anything
you're not trying to remember nothing
new words that you looked up nor the
other yellow words that you're reading
through at the same time in which you
still can't remember but you look them
up again none of that matters what I'm
finding is another advantage of power
language learning like I'm doing is that
it increases your ability to accept
imbuing ambiguity uncertainty you don't
understand it doesn't matter so there
was a question I can't remember who it
was I think it's of our friend from
Ukraine said you know even after linking
all these words in agonal now you know
my screen is covered in yellow which are
words that I now have at least in my
database and I still can't make sense of
it that's true and it's certainly true
in Turkish where the structure is very
different from European languages
Ukrainian or Russian or English however
you have to trust that eventually it'll
become clearer so you have to accept
ambiguity for quite a while always
forgetting always not understanding and
accept that eventually will become
clearer if you keep going you're going
to gradually get a sense for the
language and so another thing that I'm
hoping with sort of doing three
languages at the same time is that first
of all it's gonna help me get a sense
for these languages I'm kind of going
over them not worrying about what I
understand although in fact
understanding more and more but I think
it's also going to help me notice and
you have to notice in language learning
I often mentioned the case of my father
you have to both notice and accept so my
father was born in Czechoslovakia was
thanks to the austro-hungarian Empire
and he went out and lived in Canada for
thirty years or longer he spoke
excellent English had a
wonderful vocabulary was totally at ease
in English but would always say things
like Nova Scotia
that's a province in Canada Nova Scotia
or Ward instead of word he is able to
pronounce those words he's able to
pronounce shut Nova Scotia he could say
that if he wanted to or if he noticed it
he can say bird herd but he says ward
because it's written wor D so he hasn't
made the transition from how something
is written to how it's actually
pronounced either he hasn't noticed or
he hasn't accepted or he's unwilling to
accept that that's how it's pronounced
in English to be good at a new language
we have to notice what's going on and we
have to accept it without resisting and
without questioning it and I think that
going after three languages at the same
time is gonna help me be better at doing
those things so I'm gonna stop it here
this is my first quickie summary on
power learning week 1 and you can expect
to hear more of this including tomorrow
I'll cover the same ground in Japanese
or marvelous bye for now
[Music]